hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video
i'm going to tell you what i think are
the five most promising
anti-aging compounds that i will
definitely be keeping my eye on
so i'll tell you not only what they are
and what they're thought to do
in terms of their anti-aging properties
but also why i think they're promising
but before we jump straight into it
there are just a few important things i
want to say first
firstly just a disclaimer these are not
recommendations these are just my
opinions based on the current evidence
we have
and as i'll reiterate at the end of this
video there's still a lot of work that
needs to be done to try and understand
the long-term effects of these different
compounds in terms of not only their
efficacy but also their safety
especially in terms of the dose and more
on from that these
are just five compounds out of the more
than 200 compounds that have now been
classified as jury protectors
and even as i was making this video my
mind did change
as to which ones i was going to include
and as a bonus i did actually include
two more at the end of this video but my
point is is that there's still a lot of
research that needs to be done
and i'm certain that you as well may
agree or disagree with the
five that i'm going to mention here and
so if you have a different
top five then put them in the comments
it'll be great to see what people have
as their five most promising
and so the thing is is that my top five
could also change over time
and so i guess if it does significantly
depending on what research comes out
then i could always update this top five
in future videos
so you want to subscribe so you don't
miss out anyway
if you do find this video interesting
then i'm certain
you're going to like the resource that
you can find on the life extension
advocacy foundation's website
whereby they have a rejuvenation roadmap
that basically
shows you quite nicely where different
jury protective
agents are at in terms of their clinical
process
and i guess the last thing that i want
to briefly mention before i begin
is why is it so important to understand
these different anti-aging compounds
well by 2050 the number of people over
60 is expected to reach
2 billion worldwide roughly 22 of the
population
whilst in 2015 it was only 12 percent of
the population
however whilst there is a trend of
increasing lifespan
there's also a trend of increasing years
spent with chronic diseases
this includes age-associated diseases
such as diabetes cancer
and alzheimer's disease one way of
dealing with this is to treat these
different diseases separately
this places a big burden on the
healthcare sector
an alternative strategy would be to
target the aging process itself
and alleviates the chances of developing
multiple morbidities
so the five compounds that i'm going to
tell you about
i've chosen based on what potential i
think they have in terms of improving
health span
instead of lifespan however by improving
health span there may also be
benefits of increasing lifespan as well
and this is why
i particularly like leaf's rejuvenation
roadmap because they split up these
different compounds
in terms of their effect by looking at
which different hallmarks of aging
they're most likely to have an impact on
so in no particular order here are my
top 5
most promising anti-aging compounds
so the first compound is
alpha-ketoglutarate
alpha-ketoglutarate otherwise referred
to as akg
is a really important metabolite found
within your cells
playing a key role in the krebs cycle
this is essential for the oxidation of
fatty acids amino acids and glucose
to generate atp that is the energy
source of your cells
but akg can also act as a cofactor for
different enzymes including prolial
4-hydroxylase
which is used to generate
4-hydroxyproline that's important for
the synthesis of collagen
and akg also plays an important role in
detoxifying ammonia
now i first spoke about akg earlier this
year
when a cell metabolism paper showed that
akg
when delivered as a calcium salt
extended health span in both male
and female mice and also extended
lifespan in middle-aged female mice
now measuring health span is notoriously
quite challenging to do
and the way that they measured this in
this study was by using a clinically
relevant
frailty index that assesses 31 different
phenotypes
this includes visual factors such as
loss of fair color
as well as physical factors such as tail
stiffening
in addition to looking at their
breathing rates and for example
whether or not there's any hearing loss
or visual loss and one of the most
striking features that they found in the
study
as i mentioned in my previous video was
the changes seen in their fur when the
mice were treated with akg
and they also found in the study that
akg didn't reduce the number of
senescent cells but it reduced the
inflammatory secretion of the senescent
cells
for example you can see a reduction in
interleukin 6 in the blood plasma
so given that akg treatment impinges on
some of the different hallmarks of aging
such as cellulosin essence and
intracellular signaling and metabolism
as well as the fact that akg is
generally recognized as safe
i think that akg is a promising
potential anti-aging supplement
moreover i more recently mentioned a
study whereby akg ameliorated
age-related osteoporosis via regulating
histone methylations
and so given that looking at epigenetic
modifications
seems to be one of the better ways of
being able to determine
biological age as an indication of
whether or not
anti-aging supplements are effective it
will definitely be interesting to see
some dna methylation data in regards to
akg
treatment and another reason why akg is
on my list is because a clinical trial
of akg involving 45 to 65 year olds
is currently being planned at the center
for healthy longevity
at the national university of singapore
and this trial will look at the
epigenetic clock as well as standard
markers of aging
including pulse wave velocity and
inflammation among others
and so as said here by brian kennedy
this opportunity will allow us to go
beyond anecdotal evidence
with real clinical data to help inform
physicians and consumers
to improve health within the context of
aging so that's definitely exciting news
and so i'll be sure to keep you updated
as we learn more
now next up on my list is metformin
now metformin is a medicine used to
treat type 2 diabetes and it can also be
used when treating polycystic
ovary syndrome and like with akg
metformin has been shown in a study to
improve both health span and lifespan in
mice
now metformin has been used for more
than 60 years in the treatment of type 2
diabetes
and generally it's been seen to be well
tolerated
however adverse effects have been seen
including diarrhea
nausea and abdominal pain in terms of
the mechanism of action
again it's slightly similar to akg and
that it impinges
on nutrient signaling and metabolic
processes
a monster isn't fully understood how
metformin acts
it is thought that it acts through
inhibiting oxidative phosphorylation in
the mitochondria
reducing oxidative stress and also by
activating
the protein amp kinase which suppresses
growth signaling pathways including that
of mtor
which sneak preview will be coming back
to later and it also impinges on the
insulin response
hence its use in the treatment of type 2
diabetes
and interestingly it's also been shown
to influence the microbiome which may
also explain its mechanism of
action and in the video i released
earlier this year
there was some infantry evidence that it
could also reduce age-associated
inflammation
now the main reason that metformin is on
my top 5 list
is because of the targeting aging with
metformin trial
that is a planned six-year clinical
trial at 14 leading research
institutions
across america that will engage over 3
000 individuals between the ages of 65
to 79
and the idea is in this trial they're
going to test whether those taken
metformin
experience delayed development or
progression of age-related chronic
diseases
such as heart disease cancer and
dementia and so this would give us a
really good insight
into whether or not metformin could
actually try and improve health span
and reduce the onset of different
morbidities
now the cool thing with this trial is
that they hope the fda will actually
approve aging as an indication to
signify that aging can be treated
so that's the idea that drugs can be
used to target
aging itself as opposed to treating
age-related diseases
however the troll hasn't started yet but
they do have their 14 clinical trial
sites committed
and interestingly they are working on a
biomarker study but as they say on the
website
if this tame trial is successful and
aging is made an indication for
treatment
a new era of treatment will be available
so for those reasons that's definitely
why metformin is on my list
now next up are nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide precursors
this includes the precursors
nicotinamide mononucleotides nmn
and nicotinamide ribosides as well as
niacin
so these are precursors for nad plus and
nad plus is a really important cofactor
within our cells
that has two major functions firstly
acting as a redox coenzyme
and alternating between its oxidized and
reduced state
and secondly as a substrate for nad plus
dependent enzymes
including sertoins which we'll also
maybe be coming back to later
and i've spoken about nadplus quite a
few times on this channel and so i'll
link down a couple of videos in the
description if you want to know a bit
more about it
so energy plus levels have been shown to
the climb of age
and mechanisms that increase levels of
nad plus have been shown to extend
lifespan in yeast worms and mice
but as i said in this video i was more
interested in looking at healthspan as
opposed to just lifespan
so it's interesting to see that in these
wealth of studies
nad plus supplementation has also
protected against age-associated
declines in mitochondrial dysfunction
physical performance fission and
arterial dysfunction just to name a few
and so you can actually get these
precursors from foods for example animen
can be found in broccoli and avocados
for example
and niacin can be found in tuna and
salmon
however eating these foods wouldn't be
enough to match the levels of nad plus
gains in these different animal models
so an alternative way is to take these
nad plus precursors as supplements
now unlike with metformin whereby we
have 60 years worth of data looking at
the safety of taking
it in humans there isn't as much data to
look at the long-term safety
of taking different nad plus precursors
especially
in terms of what is the most effective
and safe dose to be taking
however if we go into the rejuvenation
roadmap on leaf's website
we can see that there's clinical trials
being conducted using nmn by the
sinclair lab whereby
nmn is currently in human clinical
trials at brigham and women's hospital
and nicotinamide ribosides has been
assessed in human clinical trials
conducted by chromadex which is a
company that has developed a proprietary
form of nicotinamide riboside
that has been found to be safe by the
fda so for certain
more studies are needed to really
understand whether or not human health
span can be extended
however due to the availability of nad
plus precursors
and the high interest in it in terms of
the number of studies being conducted
i thought that nad plus precursors
should make it onto my list
now next up is resveratrol which is
another compound
that can be found in foods this time in
the skin of grapes
blueberries raspberries and peanuts now
literally in my last video i spoke about
resveratrol so i'll probably keep it
quite brief here anyway resveratrol has
been shown to extend lifespan in
yeast worms fruit flies and mice when
fed on a high fat diet
and as i mentioned in this video earlier
this week
there's some human trial data whereby
resveratrol seems to be alleviating the
symptoms
of heart disease and muscular dystrophy
and the mechanism by which resveratrol
is thought to be working
is by activating the nad plus dependent
protein cert 1 which is acetoin which is
that family of enzymes i mentioned
earlier in this video
and cert one amongst many things is
thought to be able to
upregulate stress resistance pathways
within a cell
and so plays a key role in the
dysregulated nutrient signaling pathways
that is one of the hallmarks of aging
and so for these reasons resveratrol
made it into my list
however i want to emphasize again as i
have done in my previous resveratrol
videos
that it seems like there may be dose
dependent impacts on the cell in terms
of benefit or negative consequences
and so it'd be really important to try
and identify what is the safe dose of
resveratrol to be taking
and to actually have some long-term
follow-up studies in human trials
and so the last compound that's made
onto my list
is rapamycin that is currently given to
patients
undergoing transplants as a means of
immune suppression
to prevent rejection of new organs so
robomycin has quite an interesting
history
and there's a lot of data that has shown
that rapamycin increases lifespan in
several muscle organisms
such as yeast worms and mice and also
delays the onset of many age-related
conditions in mice
this is nicely demonstrated in this
table here whereby you can see rapamycin
impinges on many different tool marks of
aging including impaired proteostasis
mitochondrial dysfunction altered
nutrient sensing
stem cell dysfunction cellulosin essence
and impaired intercellular communication
and so it turns out i haven't really
spoken about rapamycin before in this
channel
but the way that it acts is by
inhibiting the mammalian target
of rapamycin complex one so the target
was named after
rapamycin's discovery hence the name and
mtorq1 as a complex is really important
in regulating metabolism and growth
within a cell
and so by inhibiting this activity it
reduces signaling through the growth
pathways and instead
convert signaling more towards stress
resistance
and now rapamycin was one of the last
minute changes to my
list and although it was one of the
first if not the first
anti-aging compound that i came across
however high doses of rapamycin used in
trans block patients
has been shown to cause side effects
including poor wound healing
elevated blood cholesterol levels and
mouth ulcers
and so one way to circumvent this would
be to use a lower dose although this may
also reduce the anti-aging benefits
an alternative strategy as demonstrated
in this
paper is to have transient rapamycin
treatment
that was shown here to increase lifespan
and healthspan in middle-aged noise
and another alternative is to use
rapamycin analogues
that may have higher efficacy and lower
side effects
however this is still much under
investigation but the reason i added it
to my list is that there doesn't seem to
be any particular reason
to write rapamycin off completely yet
given the number of studies that do show
potential anti-aging mechanisms and if
you want to learn more about it
there's a really interesting opinion
article that i'll link down in the
description below
that basically details the entire
history
of rapamycin and all of the studies that
have demonstrated
the use of rapamycin for longevity so if
you are interested i'd
recommend you check that out so these
are my top five
promising anti-aging compounds and to
reiterate what i said earlier
they are only my most promising because
there is still much work to be done
in terms of finding the right dose in
terms of efficacy but also safety
and also better understanding of the
timing of when these different
compounds should be taken and these are
just my opinions
not advice in fact some of these
compounds are not even necessarily
available to you
at the moment however some of them are
and if you are interested you can get
ten percent
off at do notage.org if you use the
discount code
cheeky but please consult with your
doctor and do your own research first
and now as i said earlier in this video
it was quite hard for me to decide on my
top five and so i've included two bonus
compounds as well just briefly here at
the end the first one is spermadine
which if we go back to that table i
showed you earlier
it also seems to impinge on a variety of
different hallmarks of aging
similarly to rapamycin and the second
one is physin
that has been shown to extend health and
lifespan by acting as a cenolitic
which is a word used to describe a
compound that can kill
senescent cells and there are some human
clinical trials being conducted at the
mayo clinic
and so i mean both of these probably
could have been included in my top five
so maybe instead i'll do separate videos
on these that's a future date
if there's more research to talk about
but i thought it'd be fun to just kind
of
pick five because top five sounds pretty
good
anyway i hope you've learned something
in this video and it was somewhat
entertaining and interesting
um be sure to let me know what your top
five are obviously i think that even my
own decision could probably be changed
in light of more evidence
but yeah i think again going back to my
original points there's still a lot of
work to be done
in terms of really trying to identify
the correct and most optimal dose to be
taking
as the last thing you want to be doing
is taking something that could be more
harmful than it is useful
but anyway on that note i hope you've
learned something and as always thanks
for listening